So, there are a couple of basic
activities of doing activity
recognition.
One, I'm thinking of as model
based action recognition.
So, you have some way of getting the
pose, or the appearance of a human body.
And, you're going to relate these
descriptions of the change, or the pose,
or appearance to some action labels.
And, probably build a classifier,
or something like that.
And one of the main challenges
in doing that work is,
are your data that you use
from training taken from
a different context than the data where
you're doing the actual recognition?
These problems tend to be pretty easy.
If I have training data from
the place that I actually, and
the camera,
in which I want to do the recognition.
And, are much more difficult if
the training data come from a different
source.
Model based activity recognition
basically assumes I've got
some low level process for
either detecting actions,
maybe probabilistically with some noise.
And then, what I need to do is recognize
the overall activity by comparing it to
some, I put structural
representation of the activity,
something that defines how the different
actions relate, one to the other.
One of the reasons I sort of like
talking about it this way is it's
sometimes reasonable to get lots
of examples of low level actions.
So, you can do our traditional
building a classifier to do that.
But, harder to get lots of examples of,
the overall activity.
There's some change in that lately
in terms of using large data sets.
I'll talk about that in a little bit,
but
in some sense those are a some
what artificial problem.
When you do this, you have this
problem of handling uncertainty.
That is, your low level detections are
uncertain, and your descriptions vary.
And, you have to be able to recognize
the activity in the presence of this
uncertainty.
And, some of the major
challenges are you know, just,
can you keep track of
which part is which?
Who is who?
If you've got multiple things
going on in a train station,
there's lots of ambiguity and occlusion,
and being able to say what the activity
is is sometimes difficult when you're
subject to those those variations.
Recently, there's been some work where
you actually don't do as much about
that, you just view activity as sort of
a big space-time pattern of some sort.
So you're not actually tracking bodies,
or, you don't even know
there are people there.
You're basically just describing
the overall pattern of motion, and
you typically train a classifier.
We'll mention that
just a little bit here,
but, not spend a lot of time on that.
Also recently, and this was kind of,
I, I found it kind of funny,
there's been doing activity
recognition from a single image.
And, you might ask, you know,
how is that possible?
>> How is that possible?
>> Okay, thank you Meagan.
I didn't really want
her saying anything.
Yes, how is that possible?
Well look, here is a picture.
Okay?
So you see that, that says, imagine
a picture of a person holding a flute.
Well, you don't have to imagine it,
there it is.
You could say, what are they doing?
Right?
And, you could say,
they are playing the flute, right?
Playing a flute is an activity.
So, even though I'm only recognizing
a particular pose, in fact,
when I go like this, you could almost
hallucinate the flute being there.
Right?
Even though it's not really there, and
you can think about whether that's
a vision problem,or an AI problem, or
a hallucinogenic problem.
But whatever it is,
the idea is that you recognize
the activity from a single pose.
And, I don't really think of
that as activity recognition.
What I think of that is sort of
representative image recognition, right?
This is, this is sort of the canonical
image that you have in your mind of
the pose of a person
doing that activity.
So, you're recognizing
the pose in the context.
You're not, you might even be
recognizing the fruit, the fruit,
the flute, as is here.
I guess you could play fruits too,
I don't know.
You can recognize the flute,
and that helps you see that
they're doing flute playing.
But to me, it's, it's kind of far cry
to to call that actually activity
recognition in terms of
anything like video.